my parents got divorces when i started
using humor as a defense mechanism
put chandler bing seth cohen and jeff
winger in the same room and they'd drive
each other crazy figuring out which one
of them is the funniest
so where was i for fun time for some
being witty comes as naturally as
breathing it's liz lemon's defense
mechanism jim halpert's way to liven up
office life and how gina linetti
outsmarts everyone
here are the wittiest characters we love
from our favorite tv shows
but i mean can we just take a moment to
celebrate me sure schmidt's kind of
neurotic
definitely opinionated and charmingly
self-centered but he just brings so much
energy to his eclectic group of friends
schmidt's wit is often a result of him
being unaware of his own quirks which is
why he needs the douchebag jar
and often ends up with his foot in his
mouth his pride makes him want to seem
clever
even when he has no idea what he's doing
but he's so extra that he makes up for
any mishaps by being one of the most
exciting friends anyone could hope to
have pine has no place in this loft
it's the wood of poor people and
outhouses sometimes it seems like seth
cohen
invented sarcasm but he's so endearing
and approachable it's like his wit
literally rubs off on the people around
him he uses his good humor to cope with
hopelessly crushing on summer
always has a one-liner for an awkward
moment and just can't seem to resist
being
himself he's also really good at
portraying exactly how a teenager puts
up with embarrassing parents
thank god man are you ready to go ah the
one-liners the self-deprecating humor
and that glorious
sarcasm chandler has an overwhelming
need to be the funniest of all but it
works out because he makes fun of his
friends
and himself chandler's friendship with
joey in particular gives him the perfect
opportunities to show off his quick wit
it's one of his most defining
characteristics and it's literally a
part of who he is
remember when his new year's resolution
was to stop making fun of his friends
and he had
the worst time ever oh this must be
killing you
what makes jim so great well he can make
everything into a joke without being
annoying
makes working in an office look
entertaining can be petty in the best
way
and offers up the best commentary on his
co-workers crazy antics
jim and dwight always keep each other on
their toes and it takes some
sharp wit to be able to pull off those
pranks you put my stuff in jello again
liz lemon is the queen of witty
one-liners self-deprecating humor
and giving the best advice this powerful
working woman
also taught us a bunch of new terms and
was often the most relatable character
on tv
she's honest and willing to be upfront
about her flaws which makes her sharp
wit
even more respectable especially when
she's going toe-to-toe with jack
we're not stubborn we're principled
tom's wit comes from him
thinking his ideas are always the best
even when they usually aren't but you
gotta respect someone who has that much
confidence
even though he doesn't always have the
skills to back it up or the work ethic
tom just has a love for all things high
class and exclusive
no matter how weird and it takes a
creative mind to come up with his unique
lingo air conditioners are cool blasters
with a z
let's talk about jason bateman for a
second he's great at sophisticated dry
humor and he can get his point across
with just a look or the perfect reaction
as michael from arrested development
he's subtly sarcastic
and captivatingly awkward around women
but even as marty from ozark
bateman has these perfect reactionary
moments and uses his quick wit to get
out of some tough situations he's in
tons of movies but we need him to bring
his wit to another sitcom
stat and apparently every summer
hang on great minds think alike and rory
and lorelei gilmore prove it as the
sometimes troublesome
mother-daughter pair that often use
their quick wit to make life in stars
hollow
more interesting they balance each
other's crazy always have a comeback to
lighten the mood and
pick on each other as only best friends
can their wit
truly knows no bounds and any
conversation with them
ends up entertaining what nothing i just
didn't know the rodeo was in town
despite game of thrones not so
lighthearted subject matter
tyrion lannister is full of quick-witted
one-liners and plenty of comebacks after
all
his mind is his biggest strength he
provides comic relief
and is one of the most relatable
characters we all wanted to slap some
sense into joffrey
plus he gives his siblings a
well-deserved taste of their own
medicine
marcella's a sweet innocent girl and i
don't blame her at all for you
so clever it takes a quick wit to come
up with barney's pickup lines
plus putting a spin on a few
old-fashioned ones you've also gotta
have some creative humor to accept
so many challenges while barney is a
womanizer and sometimes self-centered he
also puts his cleverness to good use
supporting his friends and he always
backs it up with incredible confidence
that is so awesome a high five doesn't
even cut it high
six penny always has a good comeback
hilarious input and
while she's not as scholarly as her
friends she shows off how clever she is
in other ways penny's humor helped make
her more than just the hot girl her wit
also proved that she could always look
out for herself and she helped make the
big bang theory more relatable for those
of us who
aren't geniuses spell asthma
robert downey jr has only been in a few
tv shows but he manages to make
audiences laugh
and then cry with his quick wit in
whatever role he plays
he's complex as tony stark and brings a
cleverness to iron man that not only
shows off his great mind but also his
ability to find the fun in the serious
role of a superhero but rdj has some
equally hilarious moments on the small
screen
he played larry paul and ally mcbeal
which highlighted the actor's comedic
skills looking back it just proved that
he can bring his natural wit
and good humor to any character take
that off what are you
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist will smith is always
clever with his humor and fresh prince
whether he's making jokes about
carlton's height
or trying out a new pickup line even
when they get a little predictable
he always knows how to get his way will
is also great at breaking the tension
and his jokes are memorable
and still get quoted to this day his
mishaps are refreshingly funny and he
can turn a bad situation into comedic
gold take this his royal freshness
that's dope
gina linetti's always got something to
say has unmatched confidence a love for
bragging
and she's usually pretty selfish but
she's also impossible not to love
probably because she's so ambitious
entertainingly over the top and
a great friend even though she won't
admit it understanding how her mind
actually works is a challenge but one of
her friends are more than happy to
accept
but go get him before i change my mind
up
i already changed my mind max black uses
wit as a self-defense mechanism but it
makes her refreshingly honest
incredibly sassy and downright relatable
she pretty much says what we're thinking
but would never say out loud her wit
and sarcastic one-liners also make her
the perfect balance to bubbly caroline
and in return caroline tries to help her
see the positive side of things which
works
um sometimes don't be ridiculous your
luck
couldn't get any worse
there's no one who can offer a plus
medical expertise
a sarcasm and make fun of their
coworkers better than dr cox his rants
can go
on and on and on but there's no denying
they're clever
it's pretty much impossible for him not
to respond to everything with sarcasm
and biting humor he might just be the
funniest character that we're also
afraid of
that 70s show has a few characters that
could be classified as witty but eric's
wit
is the centerpiece of the show and his
timing is always impeccable eric's a pro
at quick one-liners picking on his
sister and he's perfectly sarcastic the
fact that his father is so unimpressed
by his humor just makes eric seem even
funnier
we treated him like our own son treat
him better than your own son
there's nothing jeff winger won't make
fun of he's got great comebacks and a
huge ego to match we can't forget those
classic wingers
thankfully he uses his wit for good
instead of evil well
most of the time at least he makes up
for it by using his humor to protect and
look out for his friends
and he helps keep things from getting
too serious you mean like
marriage i mean a mental institution ah
so do i
darlene excels at making fun of her
family she's the troubled child that
even a slightly rebellious teen can
relate to
she's also always catching people off
guard and has some of the best
one-liners on tv
the best thing about darlene is that she
stays true to herself
and always says exactly what she's
thinking well no one was home so i
figured why not become a woman
being witty is a huge part of her
personality all of the golden girls are
funny
but dorothy is probably the wittiest
she's sarcastic
always tries to have the last word and
has given us a gold mine of clever
insults over the years but the best part
she makes fun of her siblings while
still always taking care of them
proving that wit can be an effective way
to cope and find the silver linings in
life
it's basically a superpower you've been
practicing for this part for a lifetime
haven't you
who are your favorite clever characters
anyone you'd love for us to discuss in
an upcoming video
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to hit that like button
while you're here and subscribe to our
channel for more thanks for watching